[Música]
incertidumbre y protestas en Guatemala
después de que la corte constitucional
suspendiera los resultados de la primera
vuelta de las elecciones generales en
esta edición analizamos el panorama de
cara al balotaje previsto para el 20 de
agosto
este fin de semana Andrés Manuel López
Obrador cumplió 5 años en el gobierno
con un 60% de popularidad el presidente
mexicano se dio un baño de masas en la
capital y defendió sus políticas contra
la desigualdad mientras entra en su
último año de mandato
en Estados Unidos un nuevo tiroteo
sacudió la ciudad de Baltimore este
domingo un ataque armado en una fiesta
popular causó dos muertos y 28 heridos
las autoridades avanzan en la
investigación sobre lo ocurrido
Bienvenidos a esta edición informativa
dedicada a las noticias más destacadas
del continente americano soy Rosa Pérez
maceu y es para mí un gusto acompañarlos
empezamos en Guatemala donde hay
incertidumbre y tensión por la decisión
de la corte constitucional el tribunal
ordenó revisar los resultados de la
primera vuelta de las elecciones del
pasado domingo por lo que está en el
aire si finalmente van a ser Sandra
Torres y Bernardo Arévalo los candidatos
que se enfrenten en el balotaje previsto
para el 20 de agosto el fallo ha
desatado protestas tanto a favor como en
contra Juan Armando rojas tiene los
detalles
entre la incertidumbre y la desconfianza
cientos de manifestantes salieron a las
calles de Guatemala este domingo para
protestar tras la orden de la corte de
constitucionalidad al tribunal electoral
de no oficializar los resultados de las
elecciones celebradas el pasado 25 de
junio la decisión se dio después de que
nueve partidos políticos den presuntas
irregularidades en el proceso
los manifestantes exigen respeto por los
resultados de la jornada en la que
pasaron a segunda vuelta Los candidatos
Sandra Torres de unidad nacional de
esperanza y el social demócrata Bernardo
Arévalo del partido semilla aquí no nos
importaría si se mía ganara pero que
gane voto sobre voto y que el pueblo
realmente lo eligió
imponiendo la Organización de Estados
Americanos tras la orden del alto
tribunal en Guatemala ronda El fantasma
de un posible fraude electoral por lo
que la sociedad civil comienza a
movilizarse reclamando transparencia en
el proceso guatemaltecos que están
cansados que alguien por tener dinero
por tener poder se adueñe de los votos
de la gente y manipule los procesos
electorales en los cuales Todos hemos
creído con más de 17 millones de
habitantes en el país está previsto al
regreso de los votantes a las urnas el
próximo 20 de agosto para la segunda
vuelta mientras se aclaran las denuncias
contra el proceso
previamente Silvia Lilian Trujillo
cordobés investigadora y docente en la
universidad Rafael landívar nos ayudó a
entender los escenarios que se abren en
Guatemala ante esta situación inédita
Bueno yo quiero hacer una precisión
primero el amparo que se solicita que
nueve partidos políticos de derecha
solicitan a la supremo electoral Mejor
dicho a la corte Perdón
no suspende las elecciones y justamente
ahí está uno de los problemas
acepta las elecciones pero en todo caso
lo que pide es la suspensión de la
adjudicación de cargos entonces ahí se
abre una especie de vacío legal porque
nunca ha pasado y la ley no contempla
Qué hacer cuando se aceptan las
elecciones se dice que sí son vigentes
legítimas pero se cuestiona la
adjudicación de cargos Entonces eso
plantea un escenario posible que es que
se queden esta Perdón en standby el
proceso hasta que la corte decida lo
contrario y entonces Mientras tanto
tendríamos que ver qué sucede ese es un
escenario posible
realmente el otro escenario es que en
efecto digamos una de las cuestiones que
movimientos semilla manifestaba ayer Es
que la corte constitucionalidad no tiene
competencia en esta decisión porque en
todo caso si es el tribunal supremo
electoral a quien se cuestiona le
corresponde a la Corte Suprema de
Justicia a tomar la decisión y fuera a
las juntas electorales entonces son los
tribunales ordinarios digamos los que
tendrían que decidir es decir que la
corte de constitucionalidad toma una
decisión ayer que de alguna forma es
cuestionable porque no es su competencia
como digo ahora Estamos en una guerra
judicial ahora pareciera que las urnas
no son las que deciden los el nuevo
presidente o presidenta de la República
sino las Cortes y esto nos pone en un
problema porque las Cortes son parte
justamente de este sector del estado que
ha estado cooptado por lo que en este
país llamamos el pacto de corruptos con
lo cual insisto los escenarios son
bastante complicados porque en todo caso
la corte dice en el amparo que sí se
tiene que respetar los tiempos de la
Constitución y que sí se tiene que hacer
el veinte de agosto la segunda vuelta
en otras noticias en México Andrés
Manuel López Obrador cumplió cinco años
de gobierno este sábado y el presidente
celebró El Aniversario con un baño de
masas en la capital
cinco años desde la revolución de las
conciencias Andrés Manuel López Obrador
celebró sus cinco años en la silla
presidencial en la Ciudad de México Los
Seguidores de amlo que llenaron el
Zócalo fueron testigos y partícipes de
los festejos el presidente realizó un
recuento de su gobierno resaltando sus
logros
la justicia y tranquilidad social y se
avanza hacia la erradicación de la
violencia lo vamos a lograr entre todos
me canso ganso
un lustro de la autodenominado primer
gobierno de izquierda en México lleno de
claroscuros la política de López Obrador
se sustenta en la reducción de fondos
para funcionarios gubernamentales para
sustentar la creación de programas
sociales y la construcción de
megaproyectos de infraestructura pública
lo que le ha ganado la aprobación del
60% de mexicanos el bloque opositor
critica las reformas al sistema
electoral mexicano que propone López
Obrador y teme un giro autoritario en su
gobierno mientras el presidente menciona
que el único objetivo de sus críticos es
conservar sus privilegios no les importa
la democracia
sino lo que quieren es que continúe el
predominio de una oligarquía
es decir un gobierno
de los ricos la seguridad en México
también es una tarea pendiente para amlo
desde su llegada al poder en 2018 casi
157 mil mexicanos han sido asesinados lo
que convierte a su periodo en el más
violento en la historia del país vamos a
Estados Unidos porque este domingo
Baltimore fue escenario de un nuevo
tiroteo durante una fiesta popular el
ataque causó al menos dos muertos y 28
heridos entre ellos 15 menores de edad
era una velada agradable una especie de
fiesta de los vecinos los residentes de
este Barrio Obrero de Baltimore se
habían reunido como todos los años pero
esta vez se convirtió en una pesadilla
hacia la medianoche hora local sonaron
disparos y la policía fue alertada dos
jóvenes resultaron muertos una mujer de
18 años y un hombre de 20
Poco después de las 12:30 a.m los
oficiales recibieron múltiples llamadas
sobre un tiroteo su llegada los agentes
encontraron a varias víctimas que
sufrían heridas de bala una mujer adulta
murió en el lugar 29 víctimas fueron
trasladadas a hospitales de la zona
Baltimore es tristemente celebre por su
violencia la ciudad tiene una de las
tasas de homicidio más altas del país
pero anoche se trataba de una simple
fiesta de Barrio y a los residentes les
cuesta entender en un intento por frenar
La ola de violencia en su ciudad el
nuevo alcalde ha hecho de la lucha
contra la proliferación de armas de
fuego una de sus principales prioridades
en su opinión este último tiroteo
demuestra una vez más la necesidad de
controlar Estas armas
quiero reiterar que se trata de una
tragedia absoluta que no tenía por qué
ocurrir pone de manifiesto una vez más
el impacto y la necesidad de atajar la
proliferación de armas ilegales en
nuestras calles y la capacidad de
quienes no deberían tenerlas para
hacerse con ellas
en Estados Unidos más de 40.000 personas
murieron por armas de fuego en 2022
y cerramos con un repaso de las marchas
en América Latina este fin de semana en
pleno mes del orgullo
en Bolivia cientos de personas
desfilaron el sábado por las calles de
la Paz para reivindicar los derechos
lgbt en un país donde no se reconoce el
matrimonio igualitario entre los
participantes del desfile artistas drac
que defienden el rol de las cholitas
el desfile del orgullo de Colombia
reunió a personas lgbt en las calles de
Bogotá este domingo en 2016 la corte
constitucional de Colombia legalizó el
matrimonio igualitario cinco meses
después de legalizar la adopción para
parejas homosexuales
también las calles de Caracas se
llenaron de banderas arcoiris los
participantes marcharon para defender la
diversidad sexual y de género en uno de
los países menos garantistas de los
derechos lgbt de la región
latinoamericana
hasta que las noticias gracias por su
atención
[Música]